yeah hey you guys have any East
Fairweather and you may remember me as
your mom from the 90s big game Lisbeth
way out soon link to that madness in the
description welcome to hashtag news do
we have any To Kill a Mockingbird fans
out there huh huh no not one all right
well Harper Lee the author of the book
that you were orst to read in school
it's continuing the story of scout as an
adult and releasing a sequel 50 years
later not only my super excited read the
Cliff Notes version but this is great
news because now we all know that Harper
Lee is still alive and this comes just
days after finding out that Missy
Elliott is also still alive haha what a
world we live in go set a watchman the
title of the sequel will be coming out
later this year it's actually just been
sitting in a drawer for more than 60
years the sequel follows the characters
from the original book as full-grown
adult releasing a sequel a bunchy years
later where everyone's way older I'm
sure everyone will love it
but this isn't just a happy story of an
old book being conveniently found we all
need to keep our eyes peeled for our
girl Harper because some very shady
stuff has been reported in the last
couple of days just like her character
boo rat Harper Lee is a known recluse
she has been avoiding the public eye
ever since the release of To Kill a
Mockingbird but her sister and more
importantly business manager recently
passed away and Harper is now being
thrust into the spotlight again
considering Harper Lee was aware of this
but for the last 60 years and didn't
feel compelled to release it why then is
this book suddenly being published just
months after her trusted business
advisor dies I think this is a bit
suspicious so I decided to investigate
oh hello welcome to harper collins
publishing are you here to pitch a book
No HarperCollins huh like Harper Lee no
like our founders J&J Harper a likely
story excuse me you are publishing
harper lee's new book aren't you well we
are a book publishing company so one
that desperately needs another hit book
huh yeah book sales are down why did you
murder Harper Lee what are you talking
about she's still alive we're just
publishing her next book wait say that
again we're just publishing her neck no
at the beginning are you here to pitch
oba how about a quadrilogy about a
female detective who investigates book
crimes how does that sound boring that's
what scholastic said the publication go
set a watchman will be one of the
longest gaps in history for a major
writer and so far the reviews are pretty
mediocre I thought it a pretty decent
effort said Harper Lee well a pretty
decent effort from one of the greatest
writers of all time is still probably
far and beyond better than what
currently ranks as a New York Times
bestseller that's it thanks for watching
the latest issue of hashtag news like
this video if you want to see more tales
of Myrtle scrums book to text
let us know in the comments if you have
a better title for the sequel if you
think there's some shady business going
on or if you have a different book that
you'd like to see a sequel to and don't
forget to subscribe for more hash tag
news and follow us on twitter to get the
latest from new media rock stars i'm a
nice fair weather and never stop asking
questions who are you who brought you
here how did you get here what's your
little brother see you don't have any
brothers why what kind of toppings do
you like on your pizza you don't like
pizza get out